Dallas Cowboys owner Jerry Jones issued
an apology on Tuesday after using what
has been dubbed the m word that's M that
means in Mary
or as in [ __ ] but you can't that's
what you can't say anymore to refer to
little people during a tribute to a team
executive who recently died little
person
how is that less offensive than [ __ ]
no don't like that don't little person
sound patronizing
you're saying to the [ __ ] oh look at
that little person and no one has
explained like what exactly is wrong
with [ __ ]
what is what what is what's the inherent
quality of the word [ __ ] that makes it
offensive can you can you explain that
to me it's just been decided randomly
because this is what this is what they
do this is part of this is what the PC
police do this is their MO it's just to
go along and kind of like just randomly
change the labels for things uh that
label doesn't work anymore that's
expired it's past is expiration date we
got a new label now that we use
well why what makes it expired yeah it
just is that's it he's an angry elephant
sorry not gonna do it can't do